[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's right thompson espn senior writer
joining us from augusta uh
what what baseball hat do you have on
there
this is uh one of the atlanta braves
minor league affiliates so i'm uh uh
they were handed out minor league hats
in the press room so i had to find you
know the closest to the braves i could
get all right looks good are you in the
press room right now i am in fact in the
press room right now all right uh
conditions and how will they affect
today's golf uh in particular tiger
well i mean it rained all night at our
rental house i mean it was keeping
everybody up it was raining that hard
and it rained all this morning
uh ray's creek is up
i mean as you know they have incredible
technology here so they can suck a lot
of water out
of the fairway but it'll be a slog for
the
fans moving around i mean they can get
the water off the course but everything
else will be a mud pit
how's that gonna affect tiger
i think anything that makes walking
harder i mean i think cold in the
morning is hard i mean he talked about
that the other day that you know his leg
is full of plates and rods and screws
and
uh
you know there's something
there's something interesting and
beautiful about watching his main
opponent now just be the ravages of time
and injury as opposed to other golfers
so i mean walking is hard
for him
you know you start to look at this and
and it feels like it's uh it an
optimistic bet that the gamblers are
saying that tiger making the cut tiger
winning
and uh one sports book in vegas said the
realistic odds are about 200 to 1.
what what chances would you give tiger
to win the masters
you know you learned a long time ago in
professional sports writing that the the
rules are uh uh you know every dinner is
24.99 and don't ever bet against tiger
woods and so i mean i would never do
that and uh you know i look up at the
you know i'm looking right now at the
people who are starting and
you know
i don't see a lot of guys who want to go
head to head with tiger on the back nine
on sunday if he can get there
so i mean i you know 200 to one sure i
mean
14 months ago this guy was in a hospital
bed he stayed there for three months and
then into a wheelchair
and then in to crutches and then a step
then two steps so the fact that he's
able to walk is staggering and and you
know i i feel like
just seeing him show up here and walk
around the course is a herculean thing
to see
i mean i can't imagine
him being in contention on sunday but if
he is
he's very dangerous
and you've done a deep dive on tiger
we've talked about this before in some
of your appearances and you said
something that stayed with me and that
is that tiger
there was a stretch where he didn't like
golf he was great at golf but he didn't
like golf
where is he now in his life and what
does golf mean to him i mean i think he
likes playing with his son i think it's
a very very different game i mean you
know the first you and i talked i think
it was
i don't remember
i don't remember the context but we were
talking about you know what what's he
still playing for
and you know until he won the master
several years ago you have to remember
his kids had never actually seen him be
tiger woods
you know they had never
they didn't remember that you know he he
joked his kids thought he was a youtube
golfer so i mean i think golf is
something you know he gets to do with
his son now uh you know his son came and
played his practice rounds here at
augusta with him
uh
i it also like in some ways the pain is
probably the point more than the golf
you know the overcoming of it
it's it's more of a challenge for him to
get out of that bed and walk again than
it is to beat the current golfers like
the challenge you know he's a challenged
guy you know like a lot of people we've
covered over the year dan and uh years
dan and
i mean just
he said something tuesday that really
stuck with me which is that you know he
would decide
when it was over
and i think that has a lot a lot to do
with what we're watching
you remember the first time you
interviewed him
do i remember what do you remember the
first time you interviewed tiger
i remember
i was here
i was here the year after he won
so in 20 2003 and he seemed
so young
and strong and invincible i mean that's
what i remember he walked in the room
like this guy's jacked you know
and uh
now the hairline is in full retreat uh
he's you know has a big upper body uh
but you know he sort of walks like that
you know the guy walks around the gym
and still thinks he's young you know i
mean like he kind of has that walk
and uh
he's a 46 year old man and you know
the thing i'm curious about
is as i you know i'm excited to watch
this today but i'm curious like
what is this about for him
you know i mean i think if i could give
him truth serum that's what i'd want to
know like what what what is this exactly
and you've talked about spending time
and that he wanted to be a navy seal you
know that that was probably
more important to him than
whatever golf was going to bring to him
right right you know yeah i mean like
you know we had that
that the book out a couple years ago the
cost of these dreams that has that
that story you're talking about that
tiger story in it and uh
uh
yeah i mean i i
the through line between that and this
is that the overcoming of pain and the
overcoming of your own limitations
in some ways is more interesting to him
than getting around a golf course in
less strokes than some of his current
peers you know i mean one of the things
i've been thinking he's been thinking a
lot about certainly is ben hogan who in
1949 was driving his cadillac
from dallas to el paso and through the
ice and the fog and a greyhound bus
tried to pass a truck and just hit him
head on i mean it almost killed him then
he almost died in the hospital from
blood clots
and he came back they never they didn't
think he was gonna walk again and he
came back a very diminished version of
himself in his opinion but won six more
majors
and you know tiger is very well aware
that if he would have had his car wreck
in 1949 he would not be playing today
but uh you know he was very gracious in
thanking the whole army of surgeons and
physical therapists and physios and you
know i mean his his peers now are people
like ben hogan not people like dustin
johnson
we're talking to wright thompson espn
senior writer joining us from augusta i
couldn't help but think of you when
urban meyer was uh let go by
jacksonville
because you profiled him and you know
he's wired differently
uh what happened
are you surprised what happened in
jacksonville with urban meyer
you know
i mean one of the things that's
interesting as you you know you write
stories for a long time uh
some of them if you're lucky sort of
become even more true as time goes by
and you know that that urban story i
think is in that collection as well the
cost of these dreams but urban is uh
urban is
when i left him at the end of that story
he felt like a person who was on a
knife's edge
and could go one of two ways and you
know who was aware of his own worst
impulses and was working
uh and actually you know in my opinion
at the end of that story failing to
control them and clearly that seems like
what's happened you know that
uh and i don't enabled allowed to be the
worst version of himself
you've done so many profiles i just read
uh one that you did on mike shushewski
uh called uh you know coach k's last
march her final march i think yep um you
know those kind of guys
joe paterno was going to coach until he
died brett mussberger said that to me
certain coaches you know bear bryant
they're just guys you know retirement
scares people does retirement scare
coach k
i don't think he thinks so but i also
don't think he fully appreciates what
life will be like when he's no longer
coach k
uh i think he's tired i think like a lot
of guys
he doesn't want to cheat the process
because the joy is in the process not in
the results you know the the joy of
being a basketball coach is staying up
all night with your assistants and
ordering a 4am pizza and watching film i
mean those kind you know quick
turnarounds off
tight travel schedules so i think the
grind is the job as opposed to being
something you endure to do the job and i
just don't think he could do it anymore
and i don't think he was willing to look
at himself in the mirror because you
know those assistant coaches would have
covered for him forever you know like
joe paterno's assistance covered for him
you know i mean that was the thing no
one wanted to say when all of that was
going up is that he hadn't actually been
the head coach in a very long time and
and that was not true with coach k i
mean he was
fully in charge until the last horn blew
and i so
i don't know what he's going to do in
retirement
but i think he just couldn't do the job
the way he knew it needed to be done
who do you think is going to win the
masters
man i'm looking right now
honestly
i don't think rural rory mcilroy well i
have no factual okay you know uh
you know
i'm fascinated by rory i don't know if
you ever spend any time with him i
really haven't but uh he seems like he
is uh
very very self-aware and
like understands how understands the
ways in which this matters and the ways
in which it doesn't
so i don't know i enjoy rory i he's one
of my favorite interviews because
he does give you he thinks about what
you're asking him and gives you an
honest answer or at least the appearance
of an honest answer and and that's all
we can ask for when we're doing you know
these interviews well just for someone
to be engaged in the thought experiment
of it all yeah you know that like you
know i'm not the boogie man i'm i have
this question and let's try to figure
out an answer to it
great to talk to you hope the family's
uh good and uh i still have to cross
paths and have bourbon with you
oh uh yeah i'm so julian van winkle is
in my master's house this week he's he's
here for the tournament so uh he wanted
me to ask you how much of that whiskey
was left um
tell papi i probably need another
another bottle of 15 if i can
well yeah well you know we'll tell pappy
as soon as you sell us a bunch more
books we'll get you another one
great to talk to you right you you too
man have a great day thank you buddy
yeah uh that's uh happy van winkle and
uh if you're a bourbon
person then you know about papi and
pappy is very expensive